you know I think the idea of white
privilege is absolutely reprehensible
and it's not because white people aren't
privileged you know we have all sorts of
privileges and most people have
privileges of all sorts and you should
be grateful for your privileges and work
to deserve them I would say but the the
idea that you can target an ethnic group
with a collective crime regardless of
the specific innocence or guilt of the
constituent elements of that group there
is absolutely nothing that's more racist
than that it's absolutely abhorrent I
can't be not that if you if you really
want to know more about that sort of
thing you should read about the kulaks
in the in the soviet union in the 1920's
kul aks because they were they were
farmers who were very productive they
were the most productive element of the
agricultural strata in in Russia and
they were virtually all killed raped and
robbed by the collectivists who insisted
that because they showed signs of wealth
they were criminals and and ruins and
ants and robbers so and that one of the
consequences of the prosecution of the
kulaks was the death of six million
Ukrainians from the famine in the 1930s
the idea of collectively held guilt at
the level of the individual as a legal
or philosophical principle is dangerous
it's precisely the sort of danger that
people who are really looking for
trouble would push so and and just a
cursory glance at 20th century history
should teach anyone who wants to know
exactly how how unacceptable that is